grim reaver mentality is knowing that
nobody's messing with you you know when
you're in the moment and something's
going down
there's just nothing else i'm laser
focused on the task and
it's just something that comes out when
it has to come out
for the past three years 7-5 brewing
company has taken fans on a journey with
their different brews starting with dawn
breaker to training day then
shiver giver and now we highlight a new
chapter
the new grim reaver named after the
hockey great ryan reeves himself
is launching today and joining me is
co-founder adam coats to tell us
more about it adam thanks for joining us
tell us a little bit about 7-5 brewing
how did you and ryan come up with it
yeah thanks uh really i mean it started
right i've been best friends
back back in winnipeg since we were
eight years old and
he played hockey and i got into the beer
business and
uh when he uh finally got to vegas we
decided to uh to do something together
it was it was going to be a great uh
great opportunity for for both of us to
give back to the community and
i'm super excited of where we're at
where we're at today
now you say 7.5 brewing is bare for
everyday working people but you really
want to push this message of overcoming
obstacles tell us a little bit about
that
for sure i mean you know ryan wasn't a
first round draft pick right um
he was uh and he came up through the
minors and you know i think a lot of
people
uh you know have to work really really
hard for the goals that they set out for
themselves and really what we wanted to
do is use ryan's story as a bit of an
inspiration of
you know hard work determination and a
lot of passion for what they do
uh and and really we've told that story
throughout our beers and and you know
dovetailing off of what ryan you know
has done throughout his career but also
you know giving people inspiration to
whatever their goals and dreams are
whether it's
you know in business or in arts or or in
professional sports that
you know you work hard and you're
determined and and you pay your dues
then
then you should get rewarded for it
let's talk about this beer
grim reaper it just it sounds bold can
you tell us a little bit about it
absolutely it's a big bold stout it's
seven and a half percent
uh abv um you know it's uh
it's really sweet with some dark kind of
chocolate malt to it
uh but you know it's it's the biggest
beer in our lineup from a flavor
perspective so
as you go through dawnbreaker training
daily shivergiver and then to the grim
reaver
uh it packs a punch there's no question
and you can get it where
uh well you know one of the best places
to get our beer is always at where it's
brewed at abel baker brewing
on on main street there they have all
our beers there and it's actually where
our beers are brewed so that's a great
place to get a great place to get it
there's a lot of other locations whether
it's liquor stores or
bars and restaurants across vegas that
that carry seven five
adam we can't wait to try it thank you
give our best to revo
we know that he has been under the
weather we hope he's doing great we
can't wait to try the beer
congratulations
awesome thanks so much we'll send it
over to you jc